Innovations in modern agriculture are
critical to guaranteeing Global Food
security and sustainability a major
problem for Farmers is striking a
balance between agricultural output and
conservation initiatives as we all are
aware of the role of farmers in the
farming
agriculture they are in charge of
producing and maintaining crops and not
only cultivate and harvest it but also
care for the land and ecology as a whole
therefore farmers awareness of
innovative machines is crucial for
improving crop yields reducing labor
costs and increasing efficiency but
often struggles due to lack of
understanding if you are a farmer or
interested in knowing about the modern
technology used in farming
nowadays this video is for you because
today we are giving a detailed insight
to the top five Innovative machines a
farmer must know about so let's start
firstly autonomous farm tractors are
equipped with Integrated Systems
computers and
processors these connections transform
electrical impulses into a controller or
CPU to enable the tractor to perform
each tractor is equipped with its own
set of interconnected capabilities and
failsafe emergency
systems every autonomous farm tractor
comes with a remote emergency stop
feature for everyone's safety for
navigation tractors are equipped with
GPS enabled cameras Radars and lighters
a sensor Suite with two lighters a
camera set and a side robotic camera is
mounted on the tractor these are used to
navigate and monitor the environment and
the data they absorb is fed into the
main system one of the most significant
impacts of Automation in agriculture is
gains in efficiency and accuracy this is
absolutely true in the case of the
tractor fully autonomous farm tractors
can till and plant seeds with pinpoint
accuracy this result in better farming
Precision which leads to Greater yields
with efficient fertilizer distribution
decreased fuel waste and lower
production costs another advantage of
autonomous tractors is that cuttingedge
tractor sensors used by these tractors
collect information regarding soil
conditions and crop Health they also
collect all Harvest data prior to and
after cropping through the data
collected by autonomous tractors in
agriculture settings of every kind small
and large Farms can generate new
insights and
strategies besides autonomous tractors
enable Farm operators to get the work
done even if they can't add headcount
autonomous tractors require minimal
supervision meaning a single operator
can easily operate an entire fleet next
to autonomous tractors are drones it is
in agriculture provides several key
advantages that lessen labor expense and
resources across the industry a drone
can easily access the agricultural area
in question whether it's a tight space
or a wide open field Additionally the
Drone surveys the area and captures
highquality images which can then be
used utilized on their own or turned
into detailed three-dimensional maps all
without disturbing the farmers their
crops or the surrounding environment
this allows Farmers to better plan their
seed planting patterns conduct soil
analysis and stay upto-date with how
their plants are growing furthermore
drones can address any issues that arise
in real time such as issues with pests
or other unwanted visitors crop yield
weather and other agricultural
contingencies apart from that the photos
and real-time coverage drones provide
enable Farmers to inspect irrigation
equipment monitor pesticides and
fertilizers and gather plant and
environmental data additionally equipped
with large reservoirs for fertilizers
herbicides or pesticides drones can be
used for this purpose and it works safer
faster and much more cost cost effective
besides disseminating pesticides and
fertilizers they also allow for a
precise measurement of plant Health
allowing for a more controlled
application of these sprays next is
smart irrigation systems an Innovative
technology that farmers can incorporate
into their existing irrigation system
they automate Monitor and analyze water
consumption helping to reduce waste
detect leaks and alert the farm farmers
of any potential problems also smart
irrigation systems monitor weather soil
moisture evaporation and plant species
to automatically adjust watering
schedules irrigation work can be carried
out by time and area avoiding the waste
of water caused by traditional preset
irrigation the managers can remotely
control it through a mobile phone or
computer no need for the irrigator to
manually open or close CL the water
valve another Innovative machine is
harvesting robots that are designed to
harvest crops they use sensors and
cameras to detect when the crops are
ready to be picked then robots are used
to harvest them without damaging the
produce additionally these robots remove
weeds from Fields without manual labor
weeding robots use image recognition
technology to identify weeds and to
remove them from the soil
these robots crawl over top the produce
looking for weeds additionally farmers
can use these robots for tasks such as
soil analysis planting and even
harvesting in some cases robots use GPS
and other Technologies to precisely
plant seeds in the soil ensuring optimal
spacing and depth for each seed
traditional fertilization methods often
involve spreading fertilizer across
entire fields
which can be wasteful and lead to uneven
distribution now fertilizer application
robots can apply fertilizer directly to
the plants or soil reducing waste and
ensuring that each plant receives the
right amount of
nutrients some robots use pneumatic
systems to shoot fertilizer pellets into
the soil While others use Liquid
Fertilizer that is sprayed directly onto
the plants by using robots for
fertilizer application farmers can
reduce costs and increase yields
additionally because these robots can
operate autonomously they can work
around the clock which can be useful
during busy planting or harvesting
Seasons the last but not the least in
Innovative machines are biochar
generators that play a vital role in
sustainable
agriculture biochar generators convert
organic waste into biochar a type of
stable carbon which can be applied to
soil it can enhance soil fertility
structure and water holding capacity
also sequestering carbon and reducing
greenhouse gas emissions in agriculture
biochar can improve crop yields reduce
soil erosion and promote healthy soil
microbiota biochar generators use
pyrolysis a technique that includes
heating organic material in a low oxygen
atmosphere the generator warms the feed
stock to a high temperature converting
it into charcoal bio oil and sing gas
additionally biochar generators provide
a holistic solution to some of today's
most pressing concerns by enhancing soil
Health sequestering carbon managing
trash producing renewable energy and
protecting the environment as we address
concerns such as climate change resource
management and economic development
biochar
generators will likely play an
increasingly important role in promoting
a more sustainable and resilient future
we hope you enjoyed the video if yes
then like the video and subscribe to our
channel to get notifications of our new
videos thanks for watching stay blessed